the world's best guides to non-fiction
books come from our sponsor short form
short form offers comprehensive coverage
to thousands of top non-fiction books so
you can learn more faster unlike other
summary Services their guides provide
valuable insights counter arguments and
analyzes for a well-rounded
understanding of the topic try it free
and get 25 off using my link below
one of the emails that I get over and
over again from people in the audience
in some form is something along the
lines of hey you know David things seem
so terrible things seem so hopeless I'm
kind of fantasizing about just checking
out not paying attention to news anymore
not paying attention to politics anymore
not voting not engaging in any way for
the political system with the political
system and this isn't like an Off the
Grid checking out where you're going to
live in the middle of nowhere and
generating all your own electricity and
growing your own food I'm not talking
about that sort of checking out I'm
basically saying you're just not going
to follow the comings and goings of the
political system and news and the like
of it and you'll just engage with stuff
that you like video games or sports or
whatever the case may be chopping wood
Etc and often when this question is
asked we on the left and sometimes on
the right but today I'm talking to
someone on the left to my uh colleagues
on the left
sometimes we on the left will respond
with this super rigid and sanctimonious
response that not only does it make
sense to stay involved but it's the
right thing to stay involved it's
virtuous to be involved and you're sort
of failing in some way you're bad in
some way if you choose to check out and
stop paying attention and I don't think
that's the right approach
and to some degree what makes sense
really depends on the individual to just
admonish and criticize people in the
sanctimonious way because they want to
bail on what's going on because it's so
depressing or negative is actually not
really something to be criticized it
does depend on how you're affected
emotionally in your day-to-day by
following what's going on in the news
and the political system or not where I
want to be super clear is that whether
or not you pay attention politics will
affect you what I mean by that is we
shouldn't lie to ourselves about that
component just because you stop voting
and just because you stop paying
attention doesn't mean you won't be
affected by the decisions that are made
by our local politicians about roads and
Zoning or that your kids won't be
affected by decisions made at the local
school board or the PTA meeting or that
your state won't be affected by
decisions made by the governor or the
president so politics affects your
health care depending on who's in charge
maybe you have access to Affordable and
Quality Health Care or maybe you don't
politics affects education depending on
who's in charge there may be robust
public schools that are well-funded and
inclusive and function or there may not
be politics will affect our environment
depending on who's in charge there may
be policies that endanger the climate
and and spew pollution and whatever or
you might have policies that are working
to fix that politics affects your rights
depending on who's in charge we may have
laws that robustly protect civil rights
or we may not so I'm not going to both
sides that part of it however it is okay
to say for me or for you or for whoever
the emotional toll that this is taking
doesn't justify the comings and goings
of what's going on and I'm going to stop
paying attention it's not useful to
anybody including the people who remain
involved to have a group of people
involved but only under some kind of
guilt or pressure that you must follow
the news and see what people say on
social media and whatever the case may
be in fact I would actually make the
argument that we all benefit if the
people who are engaged are engaged in a
healthy way and that those for whom it
has become unhealthy do disengage I
think we're all better off in a
particular sense so this is why at the
end of the day when someone calls me and
says hey my daughter is trans and I live
in Mississippi and I'm thinking about
just getting out the sanctimonious side
will often say You must stay and you
must fix Mississippi from the inside out
if you bail we all lose and that's bad
but at the end of the day we have One
Life to Live of and if what you need to
do to keep your daughter safe is to
leave Mississippi and go to a blue State
we should understand that that's a
logical decision in the same way the
same might apply to engaging with news
and politics we need to have people
engaged in a healthy way now what does
this mean well maybe you adopt one of my
habits which is part of the week you
take yourself out of paying attention to
this sort of stuff I do this on the
weekends I'll see people Sunday and
they'll say David did you see that thing
that happened on Friday night and I
won't because I am it's it's a
deliberate checking out of news and
politics disconnecting from social media
can make a lot of sense checking out can
be good for your mental health Studies
have shown that limiting your exposure
to negative news and social media can
reduce stress levels and improve your
mood I tell you this at my own Peril
right because I do a show okay
um checking out for periods of time can
help avoid information overload and the
cognitive biases that distort your
perception of reality checking out for a
bit can help you reconnect with yourself
so let's try to be a little less
judgmental and I'm sorry I'm using the
word again but you know because of
Rhonda sanctimonious but let's be a
little less sanctimonious with this
stuff let's drop the arrogance of
pretending that you me or anybody in
particular knows the exact level of
Engagement that everybody's supposed to
have with news or politics well at the
same time recognizing that if we all
check out
the right wing winds much more easily
which we don't want so what seems to me
to be the happy medium is do not let up
with engaging as far as voting is
concerned stay engaged because it also
allows you to inspire others to create
positive change when you share your
views and your stories you can influence
the opinions and attitudes of others but
at the same time figure out a healthy
engagement and recognize that the
Instinct you're having of wow I might
just be much better off day to day
emotionally
if I stop paying attention to all this
crap then just watched fun shows and
played sports or whatever the case may
be that's logical given all of the
insane negative stuff that's going on
and let's not judge people who feel that
way while also laying out a way to stay
engaged that allows a more healthy
day-to-day that's my sense of it and
even as the host of this show I do a lot
of this stuff myself let me know what
you think uh there are people gleefully
cheering that serial rapist and child
sex offender Larry Nasser has been
stabbed in prison now if you don't
remember the story I'm going to tell you
about it and I I do have a lot to say
about the reactions of some NBC news
reports Larry Nassar was stabbed
multiple times at Florida federal prison
Union official says Nassar was sentenced
to decades in prison for sexually
assaulting gymnasts including Olympic
medalists this this guy was the
osteopathic physician
who was just absolutely disgusting he's
referred to as a disgraced Sports Doctor
over many many many years he sexually
assaulted uh numerous athletes that were
supposedly under his care although it
wasn't very caring what he did and in
fact he was convicted on endless counts
he was stabbed in federal prison 59
years old stabbed twice in the neck
twice in the back six times in the chest
sustained a collapsed lung reportedly he
is stable okay so listen there are tons
of people cheering about this and often
when sex offenders are hurt or raped or
assaulted in prison you see this
reaction oh this is great he's getting
what he deserves pedophiles don't get
treated very well in prison remember
Trump even joking about oh he's gonna
become someone's bride in prison or
something like that this is not the
progressive reaction and this is not me
saying oh I'm offended I'm offended that
somebody said that it's not about that
okay you can't complain about how
dysfunctional our prisons are and our
incarceration status quo is and then
rejoice in this and I'll tell you what I
mean I understand saying you know what
it's hard to find a lot of uh feeling
bad for Larry Nasser this guy is one of
the worst of the worst I don't feel bad
that this happened okay listen I'm not
asking you to go out of your way and cry
because Larry Nasser was stabbed and I
understand that what he did is
disgusting and in some sense you can say
well he deserves to suffer and the
suffering is that he's going to be in
prison likely for the rest of his life
but I urge you to reconsider
the gleeful reaction when convicted sex
offenders are attacked or assaulted in
prison no matter what our feelings are
about the offender and this guy is the
worst of the worst when we rejoice in
their being hurt in prison we are doing
something that is completely counter to
our views prison stabbings and rapes are
not part of the punishment prescribed by
the law and so therefore when someone is
sentenced to prison that's their
punishment they're sentenced to prison
and then they're stabbed or beaten up or
raped or whatever the case may be
it's evidence that our prisons are
failing our prisons are failing to keep
prisoners safe this is something bad
it's not something to be celebrated
because violence in prison isn't Justice
it's actually Injustice and if you look
at any other country where incarceration
rates and prison conditions make sense
to us as progressives
um prisoners are are safe it's a
violation of Human Rights it's a breach
of the rule of law and it's a threat to
Public Safety when the prisons are so
dysfunctional that people are attacked
and assaulted in this way violence in
prison is also not
um going to be part of the
rehabilitation that as progressives we
say listen we we want there to be an
aspect of Rehabilitation in prison now I
am not naive and believe everybody can
be rehabilitated I don't believe that
but certainly violence in prison and
prison rape aren't even plausibly part
of that Rehabilitation and also when we
cheer for prison violence we're
essentially endorsing a culture of
brutality revenge and vigilantism that
is not only dehumanizing again it's
against what we say we want our prison
system to be so I would encourage
everybody who has been happy about this
and there have been many to think about
it a different way we should be outraged
not about Larry Nassar specifically but
about the fact that our prisons lack
total human dignity and they lack human
rights and much the same way that I'm
against the death penalty not because I
think serial murderers are great people
who should have fun lives going to
baseball games okay but because when we
support the death penalty
we are supporting killing by the state
and I don't support that we're
supporting Revenge by the state and I
don't support that so it's not about
Larry Nasser it's about as progressives
we want at minimum adequate security and
health care and proper nutrition in
prison okay and then we can talk about
education counseling actual
Rehabilitation Etc
um let's not be happy about this it's
just weird when I see supposed
progressives happy about this and uh it
is you know Larry Nasser should get to
miserably serve out his sentence in a
box for the things that he did
but he should not be stabbed that's
evidence of the failings of our prison
system if you disagree with me let me
know and make sure you're subscribed on
YouTube youtube.com the davidpackman
show and make sure you're following me
on threads I'm on threads at
david.pakman quick break back after this
one of our sponsors is short form short
form makes the world's best guides to
non-fiction books and not only does
short form Summarize each non-fiction
book itself into key points that you can
cover in just a few minutes they have
all sorts of interactive exercises to
help you apply the ideas to what you've
read to retain more the guide to each
book also includes intellectual insights
comparing and contrasting the book to
other prominent books about the same
topic so that you can contextualize the
book and understand the controversies
and the disagreements they also have
books across every non-fiction genre
from economics and politics to science
and health I was recently checking out
James clear's Atomic habits on short
form of course they have the guide but
they also have highlights they also
include other similar books about habits
and developing a routine with
differences and similarities super super
useful and a lot more than just a
summary of the book there are new guides
and articles released every week and
short form is giving my audience a free
trial plus 25 off a subscription which
is a 50 value so for the price of a book
per month you get access to thousands go
to shortform.com Pacman the link is down
below I sadly am going to discuss an
interview from CNN's new Caitlin Collins
show that is indicative of how far the
United States of America Has Fallen
specifically with regard to that other
party the Republican party and what they
now defend and support there is a
senator named Tommy tuberville
tuberville I keep hearing his name
pronounced multiple ways I don't know
okay tuber let's go with tuberville for
today and then tomorrow we'll say
tuberville
he was on CNN's The Source this is
Caitlin Collins's new show and it
debuted last night and he was asked
about an interview that he gave NPR back
in May and during that interview when he
was sort of confronted with with his
seemingly uh lack of opposition to White
nationalists he said listen white
nationalists are Americans at the end of
the day and Caitlin Collins did
something interesting which is she gave
him the opportunity to explain clarify
and expand on those comments and
tuberville actually made it worse I am
the the lens through which I'm
suggesting you watch this interview
is that this is now the Republican party
where we are is playing footsie with
white nationalists and he actually at
one point says I don't know that white
nationalists are racist if they're
racist I'm against that stuff but I I
that's an opinion that white nationalism
is racist let's start with the first
clip this is uh this is sad as much as
it is outraging I do want to give you a
chance to clarify some comments you made
recently on white nationalists serving
in the military for those who are
watching if they haven't heard your
remarks this is what you said
do you believe they should allow white
nationalists in the military well they
call them that I call them Americans
do you want to explain those comments
Senator yeah first of all uh I'm totally
against any type of racism okay I was a
footballer good to mention that coach
for 40 years and I dealt uh and and had
opportunity to be around more minorities
than anybody up here on this did you
guys catch that little slip okay so
there's two layers to what he just said
and I sort of stepped on it so we're
going to go back and listen again
in argue in in
order to prove how not racist he is he
goes I was a football coach okay so he's
saying
I dealt I I dealt with he actually is a
word I dealt with black people and then
he catches himself dealt with sounds
like it's a little bit negative I had to
deal with the burden of black people
um and then he goes you know I and so we
had every minority it's actually
stunning that this quickly it implodes
he says okay I was a football coach for
40 years and I dealt uh and and had
opportunity I dealt with no well that
sounds bad I had the opportunity to have
minorities okay let's continue to be
around more minorities than anybody up
here on this hill yeah but when our
military has been attacked was being
attacked after 9 11 after January 6th
and that was my first day on the senate
floor I thought it was I thought it was
outrageous with what senators from the
Democratic side Chuck Schumer said on
them so this is of course not an answer
Lord that night calling out people
calling people racist calling people
Nationals white nationalists white
nationalists is just another word that
they want to use other than racism uh
I'm totally against anything to do with
racism oh but the thing about being a
white nationalist is just a cover word
for the Democrats now where they can use
it to try to make people mad across the
country identity politics right totally
against that but I'm for the American
people I'm from can you imagine not
wanting white nationalists in the
military is now identity politics that
is really something else and then when
Caitlin Collins really gets to the
critical part of this which is white
nationalists are racist that's that's
what makes the if you're a white
nationalist and you get rid of the white
nationalist beliefs you're just white
you're no longer racist the racism is in
that white nationalism he goes well
that's your opinion Caitlin you said a
white nationalist is an American it is
identity politics you said a white
nationalist is an American but a white
nationalist is someone who who believes
horrific things you don't do you really
think that's someone who should be
serving in the military well that's just
a name that it's been given I mean it's
not it's a real it's a real definition
There's real concern so if you're going
to do away with most white people in
this country out of the military we got
huge problems
is he saying that most white people in
the military are white nationalists and
therefore if you got rid of the white
nationalist in the military
you'd have no white people left at all
is that what this guy's saying he's
digging the hole deeper and this is the
Republican Party Laura White it's white
nationalists that have a few probably
different beliefs right they have that
have different beliefs now if racism is
one of those beliefs I'm totally against
it I am totally Against Racism
is racist Senator well that's your
opinion that's your opinion but if it's
racism if it's racism I'm totally
against it so listen
um
the three main ideas of white
nationalism are number one white people
and by the way it's always real white
people right like it's it's European
white a European Americans white people
white people are threatened by race
mixing
multiculturalism
immigration of brat black and brown
people the low birth rates of whites Etc
that's one belief that's a racist belief
number two
white people should be seeking some kind
of a white only state a white ethno
state to preserve racial Purity and
identity that's belief number two of
white nationalists and number three
typically white people are also Superior
to non-white people now sometimes they
they know that that one's not as
palatable as some of these others so
they'll stop short of that they go
listen I don't have to weigh in on
whether white people are superior or not
but we should certainly be separate for
sure those are the if you remove the
white nationalism then it's no longer
white nationalism and what Tommy tuber
Bill is saying of course doesn't make
any sense this is where we are in 2023.
Republicans
multiple times even when given the
opportunity to clarify restating
that white nationalists are simply
Americans maybe whose views differ but
they aren't necessarily racist and uh of
course part of this is this environment
in which Trump has sort of normalized
you never back up you never backpedal
you never apologize and in a sense I
understand the reason for that because
if that's the way Trump sets the tone if
these guys start apologizing and
backtracking then all of a sudden they
seem weak and they're called beta and
all of this different stuff but the
problem of course is that people
sometimes do say the wrong thing and now
the tuberville is just doubling down on
it it's really wild stuff and we'll see
what the next follow-up is on this if
there is any this is just amazing but uh
not all together surprising
the missing so-called Witness
to Joe Biden's so-called bribery has now
been charged with multiple crimes and
might be a Chinese spy is this a
surprise to anybody The Daily Beast
reports Republicans missing Biden probe
witness faces laundry list of federal
charges gal Loft was accused yesterday
Monday of being an unregistered foreign
agent working on the behalf of China
International arms trafficking violating
U.S sanctions on Iran and lying to
investigators this is their big witness
remember the witness that was missing
this is now the person subject to
multiple uh criminal charges the missing
witness long touted by republicans in
Congress as the missing link to their
probe into alleged Biden family
corruption was accused Monday of being
an unregistered foreign agent for China
and an international arms trafficker
while violating U.S sanctions on Iran
and lying to investigators among a
laundry laundry list of other federal
charges dual U.S Israeli citizen gal
Luft had already skipped out on his bail
while in Cyprus awaiting extradition to
the U.S for a separate case in March
though he alleges the sprawling case
against him represents political
persecution and retaliation by the Biden
Administration
the house oversight committee has for
months touted a secret informant who
could provide evidence of an alleged
quid pro quo deal for foreign aid
between an obama-era Biden and an
unnamed country details remain murky and
unverified those claims partially
unraveled when James Comer in May held a
much hyped press conference where he
promised to expose preliminary findings
while failing to air any real evidence
of corruption he then offered a partial
excuse to Star witness up and
disappeared the Republican party wants
to give immunity to an alleged
International Black Market arms dealer
who may also be a Chinese spy remember
this instant classic moment on Fox News
where James Comer said the informant is
missing and Maria barteroma reacted like
this was the biggest scoop in American
history hold on
informant is now missing
well we we're hopeful that we can find
the informant now remember these
informants are are kind of in the the
Spy business hold on a second
we're hopeful that we can find them
we're hopeful that we can find them this
is where we are right now
the best evidence if you can call it
that that the Republican party has
against Joe Biden in their desperation
to get him and implicated in some crime
which seems so elusive the best they've
got is an alleged Criminal
that's been missing for years that
disappeared at one point whose own
evidence seems to have evaporated or
never materialized and that is now what
they are hanging their hats on and
um it should it come as a surprise no
probably not this is the sort of thing
they've been doing for a while and much
you know someone actually sent me an
email this morning said David whatever
happened to those hearings about rampant
crime in the United States that
Republicans were doing and I actually
had forgotten about it myself a couple
months ago there was this hearing in New
York City total dog and pony show in New
York City Republicans held a hearing
Congressional hearing because that's
where the rampant crime was even though
the crime rate in New York City is
actually lower than that of Oklahoma
City doesn't matter New York City is
where they're holding it they said this
is just one of many of these the entire
hearing went so terribly wrong so
disastrously wrong
that we haven't seen another hearing
since we haven't heard about another
hearing sense similarly with this Biden
bribery thing they've become very quiet
since it turned out it's not clear that
the tapes exist we don't know where the
informant is now the informants been
charged with multiple crimes I expect
this to continue we'll have this uh uh
Infamous clip of James Comer on our
Instagram on our YouTube channel on our
Tick Tock it'll be everywhere make sure
you're following us we're going to take
a quick break and back with some very
big stuff right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
it's terrific to Welcome to the program
today Richard Dawkins a renowned
evolutionary biologist who has really
revolutionized our understanding of
jeans memes and the origins of Life he's
also the host of the podcast The Poetry
of reality with Richard Dawkins
available on YouTube and we will be
certain to link to that I really
appreciate your time and it's it's so
great to have you on today
it's a pleasure so maybe to start you
know you've done so many interviews over
the decades I've reviewed so many of
them in preparation for our discussion
today to start with something maybe
timely and then work back into some of
some of your other work we are seeing in
the United States and also elsewhere
this new it's not new but we're seeing a
new wave of attempt to ban certain books
to challenge the validity of certain
books to contest or question whether in
some cases children in some cases high
school students in some cases even
beyond that should be quote exposed to
certain materials
can you talk a little bit about whether
you see this as a new wave of what for
example led to the fatwa against Salman
Rushdie is this a different phenomenon
how do you see it
I'm not sure I know what you're talking
about maybe this is an American
phenomenon
um what is this new trend you're talking
about well in places like Florida and
elsewhere there are lists of books that
have been submitted to be banned removed
from school libraries told to teachers
and Librarians you are not allowed to or
it would be damaging to children to
teach the that's the general Trend I'm
referring okay are any of my books on
the list
you know not on the list I've seen
that's a shame my brother enjoy that it
is good publicity in some sense for for
one's books to be on that list I'm sure
which books are on the list that I ought
to know about that you ought to know
about is harder for me to say but it's
all it's it's books that teach history
uh of the United States in certain ways
that may paint certain chapters of
American history in a less than
favorable light it's sometimes books
where characters are gay or bisexual for
example or these so it's it's really
quite a quite a gamut that it runs
I see well I'm strongly against any kind
of censorship of that kind so that
that's that's your answer to the
question uh to to to delve a little
further into the idea
um you are someone who so many times has
debated those with whom you vehemently
disagree whether it's their views about
the Bible or empiricism or whatever the
case may be my understanding of your
work generally has been that sunlight is
a useful disinfectant in many cases at
the same time there's now a discussion
being had about for example to make it
Timely
should empiricist scientists doctors
debate anti-vaccine individuals is it
good to take their views head on versus
are they given a sort of legitimacy
through these debates that may be more
damaging I watched some of your recent
conversation with Russell Brand and
although I agree with your perspective
of completely I don't know that it went
extraordinarily well from the standpoint
of changing the minds of his audience
for example what's your sense of this
I've had to wrestle with this earlier
about creationists because um once again
the problem is should you give them a
platform by agreeing if a real scientist
appears with a creationist it kind of
makes it look as though there's a sort
of Level Playing Field yes um that um
somehow there's a debate to be had and
um on the other hand
um it's couldn't be seen as a bit
patronizing if you don't and so I find
it a very difficult question
um
on the whole I've decided that I will
not debate against creationists not at
least not naive young Earth creationists
and I
um I took that actually on advice of
Stephen J Gould who's normally thought
to be a bit of an enemy of mine but and
we agree about that and he advised me
strongly not to not to do it not to give
them the platform now
um vaccine deniers
um
I suppose that is a a debate that that
we ought to be having because it is very
very widespread vaccine deniers denial
is a very widespread thing and it
influences a lot of people
um there are possibilities of
presidential candidates being strong
vaccine deniers so I think it is a
debate we really do need to have
um and um I'm not the best qualified to
do that but um epidemiologists and
doctors
um I think probably need to get out
there and have that debate one of the I
don't know if criticisms but maybe
cautionary warnings that's often issued
in any of these contexts is that these
debates by virtue of their structure
it often ends up that whoever is most
charismatic and articulate rather than
whoever is empirically correct appears
to win for lack of a better term is that
a problem that is the structure of these
conversations or is it something bigger
I think it's a big problem I I think
that's correct
um and we've seen it again in the
creationism especially as many people
are just ignorant of what the facts are
and so if somebody sounds plausible and
has a loud voice
um they are up to win the argument
although they haven't really won it
they're up to apparently uh win the
argument
um in the case of the
vaccination debate
I think I was a possibly I forget
whether I said this to Russell Brand but
I have said it to somebody else
that I may have been a little bit too
gung-ho earlier on
in
taking on board
the doctrine which applies to many other
vaccines for example the measles vaccine
the MMR vaccine
that
getting vaccinated is a public
altruistic Act
because if you do not get vaccinated
then you are part of the problem of the
spread of the epidemic and now that's
true of other diseases such as measles
yes but it's possibly not true of covid
and I'm I've heard conflicting replies
to my question about that there's
absolutely no doubt that vaccination
against covet is effective that's not in
question that's true yes what may not be
necessarily true is that to refrain from
getting vaccinated is itself an
anti-social Act
for epidemiological reasons that that
may not be entirely true yeah I mean I
think the truth of that has also shifted
from the first vaccine tailored to the
original variant where it seemed from
the data that indeed it did prevent
infection and transmission to these
later variants and later vaccines where
it seems quite effective at preventing
one's own more serious case of covid but
maybe not effective at preventing
transmission I I feel like the problem
comes where if our counterparts in these
discussions are operating in bad faith
where they were saying it wasn't
effective from the beginning we end up
almost having to appear to to backpedal
because the facts have changed yes and
because we are honest yes to some degree
because we are honest you know I I'm
wondering I reviewed some of your older
debates that you did with young Earth
creationists there there was a woman
whose name I now don't remember but it's
quite a highly viewed debate that's on
YouTube that you probably did 20 years
ago from it from an uh a young Earth
creationist organization is your view
do you feel that your opponents in
whatever debates you are engaging in
have either declined in intellectual
rigor over the last 20 or 30 years or
have operated an increasingly bad faith
over the last 20 or 30 years or has that
not been a change that you've observed
I think you're thinking of Wendy writers
Wendy Wright that's exactly right that's
exactly right um I'm not much of an
observer of of changing the changing
scene I wouldn't like to say whether
whether over 20 years
um things have changed
um I as I said I don't really do debates
anymore
um on that subject so I haven't
really the experience to answer that
question and I haven't looked at any
data
is your sense more broadly
that there is a difference today at
least when it comes to the expectations
of scientists like you and others
when it comes to
balancing what is empirically true and
what is socially or culturally
acceptable to say maybe I'm sort of
getting at either political correctness
or whatever phrase We want to apply have
have scientists had to adapt to a
different environment in the publishing
and discussion of their work
I fear they have I I think that this is
true of some scientific journals
actually lots of scientific journals
um notably in nature science scientific
American where
um editorial policy has swung in a very
political direction to the point where
scientists have to conform to a kind of
political Orthodoxy which almost amounts
to a religion and
um this I think goes against the spirit
the open Spirit of science which
I've always treasured throughout my
scientific career
and I do feel that this is a very bad
retrograde
tendency
what is the in your opinion right way to
fight that is it you know some will say
it's simply to keep saying the truth and
to but the truth is that once you're
really in the middle of it that can be
easier said than done jobs can be at
stake so on and so forth what is the
right way to push back against that well
obviously my first thought is that the
right way is to present the evidence but
if on if you've if if you're a young
assistant professor or a young postdoc
or something yes who is in danger of
losing your job losing your Grant losing
your colleagues if you speak out
and one hears horror stories of this
happening
um it's a tragedy if people do have to
self-censor
and I feel it's a responsibility for
people like me who are retired and no
longer have a job to lose
to speak out on their behalf
at least in some theoretical sense
tenure would be a protection for those
who are currently employed rather than
retired but there's also criticisms of
tenure uh at institutions of Higher
Learning do you have a position on the
role of tenure and either in enabling
these conversations or not
not really I mean I I think it's it's
something that once you've been promised
something you should people should not
renege on that Pro on that promise so if
you if you've been given tenure in good
faith then that should not be under
undermined
it should be it should be up front in in
other words that that tenure doesn't
actually mean tenure right no without
without a doubt
um let me switch gears a little bit I
was watching the trailer for the new
podcast The Poetry of reality with
Richard Dawkins and I noted that the
voiceover from the trailer is uh quite a
similar uh uh uh script of sorts from
your 1998 book unweaving The Rainbow and
one of the interesting things that's
often brought up to me and and to others
is that sometimes the view of folks like
you and others is that when you remove
some kind of biblical story God creation
story Etc you're left with a sort of
nihilistic pessimism there's no meaning
and purpose Etc and you've talked about
this before that much of the meaning is
the meaning we assign rather than what
some arbitrary text assigns or whatever
the case may be
can you talk about that a little bit in
the sense that what's concerning to me
is when I hear an argument from a
religious individual that says how can
you really prove to me murder is wrong
if you don't have some text to tell you
that my reaction always is you're
telling me the only thing preventing you
from murder is some religious text I
mean it seems as though there's another
side to that argument isn't there yes
um well coming to the first point first
um uh you're perfectly right of course
the script of the Poetry of reality
trailer is straight from my book
um on weaving the rainbow and that
entire book is about the Poetry of
science it's about the the what nonsense
it is to say that somehow is nihilistic
it somehow takes away from the Poetry
the romance of well the spirituality
actually in one sense of of science so
yes that's the answer to that now the
thing about
if you don't believe in God what's to
stop you murdering I mean if anybody
says that I think it was herb Silverman
said I'm going to step away from you I
mean you're not the kind of person I
would like to know if that's the only
reason why you don't go around murdering
people is that you're frightened of God
what a terrible terrible reason that is
what a terrible
basis for Morality that is if that's
what you call morality then I don't wish
to know you yeah I mean it gets too
often this conversation of the moral
relativism and the idea that anything
that can be science is best
approximation simply is not as
definitive at some kind of prescribed
set of rules the likes of which we get
from from religion now I would say
that's a virtue of Science and the fact
that it only goes as far as what can be
demonstrated and not Beyond and
sometimes it may not feel as
prescriptive but there are those who say
it simply doesn't feel as definitive or
as strong to me
well they may say that I mean I I think
that um
morality what's right and wrong is
something we have to discuss it's
something which
um actually does evolve
um in on a cultural scale on the scale
of cultural Evolution it evolves over
the centuries and what we take to be
morality today is very different from
what it was 100 years ago 200 years ago
even a few decades ago actually
um I've called it the shifting moral
Zeitgeist and it's manifestly the case
that
um
not that long ago
just about everybody was racist just
when everybody was sexist and and we're
not anymore and this things are moving
in the right direction
and it's quite mysterious but
nevertheless obviously true that things
are moving in the right direction I'm
not clear what's going on I'm not clear
what it is one can use a phrase like
it's something in the air something
hovering in the air but
it's
it's we mustn't get mystical about that
it's it's something it's a it's an
amalgam It's a combination of oh
um parliamentary discussion judicial
decisions
um just plain conversations in pubs in
dinner parties in in in
um courts of law in journalism in
newspapers in books
something changes as the decades go by
such that our moral standards move in a
consistent Direction and that direction
has absolutely nothing to do with
scripture far from it I mean thank
goodness it doesn't I mean because if we
if we lived if we lived our moral lives
by scripture we'd be stoning
adulteresses to death and things like
that let's pause our conversation with
renowned biologist Richard Dawkins there
we will have part two tomorrow and the
full conversation will be available on
our YouTube channel
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show we have
truly sad news today from the world of
pillows and sheets and slippers and
mostly pillows
MyPillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell a
guy whose name we have not mentioned for
a while on the program but who's been a
guest on the program multiple times he
is now auctioning off the equipment to
make pillows because the company is
suffering so badly as a direct result of
Mike pillow waging a multi-year campaign
against Lodge chicken reason and
attaching himself to election conspiracy
theories that have cost him as at most
recent uh tally 35 to 40 million dollars
this is amazing stuff the Star Tribune
reports my pillow is auctioning off
equipment after retailers pull its
products CEO Mike Lindell says annual
sales fell 100 million dollars after
several big box retailers cut ties
following his election claims remember
that phrase that they they love
um get woke go broke or go woke get
broke or the whole point is if you start
supporting social justice publicly you
will lose your business because it's bad
for business or whatever the case may be
instinctually intuitively we suspected
that it's not really true it really
seems not to be true my pillow did did
the exact opposite of going woke they
started just supporting the crazy
election lies of Donald Trump and it is
not going well and this does this make
you sad or does this make you happy
that's the question I have I want to
hear from you my pillow is auctioning
off hundreds of pieces of equipment and
subleasing Manufacturing space after
several shopping networks and major
retailers took the company's product off
the shelves
the Chaska based manufacturer recent
recently listed more than 850 Surplus
equipment items on the online auction
site kbid
sewing machines industrial fabric
spreaders forklifts even the desks and
chairs are up for auction think of that
my pillow is failing so hard that pillow
is selling the desks and chairs where
his employees sit founder and CEO Mike
Lindell said my pillow has experienced
the loss in revenue and the items are no
longer needed as the company
consolidates its operations major
retailers such as Walmart Bed Bath and
Beyond and Slumberland Furniture I've
never heard of that one all say they
will no longer sell my pillow products
as Lindell continues to falsely claim
the 2020 election was stolen from former
president Trump Lindell said in a phone
interview yesterday quote it was a
massive massive cancellation we lost 100
million dollars from attacks by the box
stores the shopping networks the
shopping channels all of them did cancel
culture on us the auction doesn't appear
related to the 1.3 billion defamation
lawsuit targeting both with Lindell and
my pillow what was that thing he used to
say about his machines we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines right well it seems now that
the machines have turned on him and that
they are no longer making pillows he is
auctioning off the machines honestly
should I look into maybe getting one of
these machines like would that would it
be an interesting thing to get one of
the famous my pillow items
um checking out on some of the things
that are available
there's a 2008 Freightliner Freightliner
Truck a four grand that would be an
interesting thing I could get one of the
pillow trucks they have all sorts of
different trucks and Sprinter vans
there's a sprinter van available for
twenty five hundred dollars this is a
fire sale you can get a pillow forklift
for a thousand bucks you can get a um an
air compressor of some kind I don't know
what I would do with most of these
things to be totally honest but it there
is some element of this that's sad but
pillow has been so damaging I could get
boxes for 100 bucks all right it's
depressing me to keep looking at that if
you think I should look at maybe
obtaining some of these items uh let me
know and we can look into that but it
does really seem like a fire sale this
could be the end of my pillow it turns
out that going anti-woke did not work
well should we be happy about this I
don't know let me know
failed former president Donald Trump
who's been indicted twice and impeached
twice and may be indicted one two or
three more times is now wildly accusing
President Joe Biden of cocaine use this
happened on his platform truth social
the back story here is that there was
cocaine found in a visitor's area of the
White House right-wing media quickly
jumped to suggest that it might be
Hunter bidens Fox News host Brian
Kilmeade suggested it might be laced
with fentanyl they pronounce it fentanyl
whatever you know what they're talking
about
um and now the failed former president
is saying maybe it was Biden's trothing
on Troth Central quote was crooked Joe
Biden on cocaine why is cocaine
capitalized we don't know was crooked
Joe Biden on cocaine when he instructed
the FBI doj to illegally invade my home
in complete and total violation of my
fourth amendment rights was he on
Capital C cocaine or various other
substances when he for the first time in
U.S history had his political opponent
who was leading him in the capital P
polls by a lot indicted and arrested
twice if you include the doj Run
Manhattan DA's office we are a nation in
Decline Capital all capital letters
here's my translation this one is a very
easy one to translate
Justice might be approaching me
I may be held accountable for my actions
and I am really really scared people ask
me David could this be defamation
against Joe Biden I didn't even talk to
a lawyer about this one it seems very
hard to imagine how a figure as public
and powerful and as well protected as
the President of the United States could
successfully sue Trump for defamation
even at the suggestion that he is on
cocaine now I want to mention one other
thing and this of course this is when
the conspiracy theories conflict on the
one hand the right is saying that Biden
has absolutely no energy he he looks the
opposite of coked up in every public
appearance and at the same time Trump is
suggesting without evidence that Biden
might be using cocaine don't you think
that if Biden was using cocaine he would
be more energetic rather than less
energetic I don't know just a question
that I'm asking but the again this is
where we are this is the former
president of the United States asserting
without any evidence suggesting without
evidence that the current president of
the United States who beat him by many
votes nationally maybe using cocaine all
right one more quick Trump story we've
really relegated the Trump stuff to like
the back pages of the show lately Donald
Trump again has posted captured to truth
Central cat turd is a Twitter account
right leaning I don't know who runs it
it's all nonsense Trump posting a
captured poll the poll asked who will
get second place in the Republican
primary
Ron DeSantis or vivec ramaswamy in this
poll
Vivek ramaswamy will according to the
voters two-thirds of those who voted on
this say that Vivek ramaswamy will end
up in second place in the Republican
primary and only about one-thirds say
that Ron DeSantis will end up in second
place in the Republican primary this is
all meant to attack Ron DeSantis now if
you look at actual polling the numbers
are very different according to polling
Vivek ramaswamy is polling 2.4 whereas
Ron DeSantis has like eight times that
level of support at 21 so if we look at
anything that is evidence-based anything
empirical
it doesn't appear as though Vivek
ramaswamy is going to Surge and surpass
Ron DeSantis but we know that the real
numbers never really mattered to these
people interestingly I do want to just
point out a little bit there's not been
any major polling shift for several
weeks which is why I've not been talking
about polling but in looking at these
numbers what you might see is that
dating back to June 20th there's been a
little bit of an uptick again for Donald
Trump and a little bit of a downswing
for Ron DeSantis although again big
picture if you zoom out and you go back
to Trump's first arrest uh Trump has
been very steady in the low 50s and Ron
DeSantis was has been very steady right
around 21. nobody else really making any
move
other than Mike Pence who has seen a
surge from roughly four to six it's an
explosive six
trust me but it is still only six what
is the uh what what is responsible for
that quite frankly I have no idea six is
still not going to get you particularly
far we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P
so many positive comments emails and
voicemails about the Rosie O'Donnell
interview if you haven't listened to it
yet if you haven't watched it yet
yesterday the interview guest was Rosie
O'Donnell one such person calling in who
loved it is the Eggman listen to this I
never realized how much sorry let's
start it from the beginning
Dave the Rosie O'Donnell interview was
so good I always kind of liked her but I
never realized how much I really liked
her I also grew up on Long Island and as
a child and a young man we always knew
all the insane things that Trump did and
when you give him a reality show and and
making out to be something he's not
um people in New York no he's not the
rest of the country in the world can
fall for it and that's what media does
um thank you so much for putting her on
it was a great interview Dave uh Shalom
all right Shalom to the Eggman and yeah
you know interviews and one of the
things about the show
is that there's a trend that's been
there for many years
interviews in general don't do that well
for us unless they are like cartoonishly
confrontational with lunatics and that
sort of thing but interviews where we
just hear from interesting people or
about interesting topics they really
don't do that well very often and people
seem to be loving the Rosie O'Donnell
interview more than a hundred thousand
views in the first 12 hours and I think
beyond that at this point in time we are
trying to get some higher profile
interviews on the show with interesting
people and at least we have a sample of
one with Rosie O'Donnell so far
um it does seem like there is a there is
interest in it so I think it's a great
thing I think quite frankly Howard Stern
saying he watches the David packman show
probably will help us secure some of
these higher profile interviews and if
you have people you would like me to
talk to that maybe we can get email in
info davidpackman.com and we'll we'll do
everything we can to make it happen all
right we have a fantastic bonus show
today
it's actually stunning The Meltdown that
Twitter owner Elon Musk continues to
have over the success of meta's new
platform threads threads is not the be
all end-all savior of social media in
fact it's very similar to Twitter in a
lot of ways but it exposes the
triggeredly nature
um of Elon Musk and Elon Musk is now
responding by proposing a penis size
contest with Mark Zuckerberg I guess
Elon Musk thinks that that would settle
something I don't know exactly what it
would settle remember you can find me on
threads at david.pakman secondly there
is a lawsuit seeking reparations for the
Tulsa Race Massacre that lawsuit has
been dismissed we'll tell you the facts
of the lawsuit and uh why it was
dismissed and we will discuss and
thirdly there is a college Republicans
convention that will be hosting white
nationalist Nick Fuentes what yes it is
all happening we will discuss these
stories on the bonus show you can get
instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com also remember that the
children's book think like a detective a
children's book on critical thinking is
available at davidpackman.com book we
Are approaching 5 000 copies sold I know
I told you yesterday it was like four
thousand we had 500 copy copies shipped
yesterday another 150 so far today we
are approaching 5
000 copies of this which is stunning and
you can get the book in Kindle or
paperback at davidpackman.com book and
please remember if you bought the book
leave a review we really need those
reviews uh 4 800 copies sold so far only
139 ratings so make sure to come back
and review the book we'll see you on the
bonus show we'll be here tomorrow it's
an incredible week of programming that's
what they tell me anyway
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the world's best
guides to non-fiction books come from
our sponsor short form short form offers
comprehensive coverage to thousands of
top non-fiction books so you can learn
more faster unlike other summary
Services their guides provide valuable
insights counter arguments and analyzes
for a well-rounded understanding of the
topic try it free and get 25 off using
my link below